A phobia is an excessive fear of a seemingly
harmless thing and those affected, go to great
lengths to avoid certain situations.
If a situation cannot be avoided, they experience
severe distress, panic attacks or even fainting.
Phobias are less prevalent among children
and older people, and more common among teenagers,
and especially girls.
They run in families or can be the result
of a traumatic experience early in life.
Phobias can be categorized into 3 types.
A social phobia is when we fear others, especially
their judgment.
Agoraphobia is the fear of a situation we
perceive to be unsafe or difficult to escape.
Specific phobias include fears of certain
things, or situations, such as heights, or
injuries and seeing blood.
Some phobias are especially complicated — such
as the famous case of the Button Boy.
It was a normal day at kindergarten when a
6 year old boy ran out of buttons to paste
on his poster board and was asked to come
to the front of the class to get some more.
When he reached for the bowl, his hand slipped
and all the buttons fell on him.
For the boy this was a deeply traumatic event.
Not long after, he didn’t want to dress
himself anymore.
He began to have difficulty concentrating
in class due to an excessive preoccupation
with not touching his school uniform.
And eventually, he started avoiding people
just to stay away from their buttons!
Life became so difficult that 4 years after
the incident the boy and his mother decided
to seek professional help.
The psychiatrists Lissette Saavedra and Wendy
Silverman who studied the case were able to
rule out obsessive-compulsive disorder (OCD),
which is often confused with a phobia, and
concluded that the boy must have developed
a speciﬁc phobia for buttons.
To treat the boy, the doctors invited the
mother and son to be part of a research project.
To assess the child’s progress throughout
the treatment, they used a Feelings Thermometer,
allowing the boy to grade each interaction
from 1, feeling happy, to 9, feeling angry.
Big, brass jeans buttons hardly bothered the
boy, but small, clear, plastic ones horrified
him.
After the boy’s feelings were better understood,
the doctors selected a treatment method.
First they tried behavioral exposure therapy,
a form of classical conditioning
Whenever the boy touched a button successfully,
he was rewarded.
They then repeated the process in various
forms.
After 4 sessions, the boy completed all tasks
and he was able to interact with way more
buttons than before. However, he felt more
distressed about buttons than ever.
When the doctors talked to the boy again he
revealed that he found buttons disgusting
and that they emitted a bad smell.
And so they wondered: did the exposure therapy
reduce his fear, but increase his feeling
of disgust?
Next, they tried Imagery Exposure Therapy.
For the seven sessions that followed, the
boy was prompted to just visualize buttons
falling on him and imagine how they looked,
felt, and smelled.
This time the boy’s self-reported levels
of distress reduced dramatically.
Even 12-months after the therapy the boy reported
minimal fear of buttons.
So why did the first treatment fail, while
the second one worked?
The first treatment changed the minds' expectations
of what harmless buttons may trigger —classical
conditioning. The second therapy changed the
mind’s evaluation of buttons themselves
– that they aren’t actually that disgusting.
In technical terms, expectancy-learning failed,
but evaluative learning, succeeded.
But treatment of a phobia may take many forms.
Social- and agoraphobia are often treated
with counseling or even medication.
Specific phobias are often treated by systematic
desensitization, today often with the help
of virtual reality.
Humor is another serious therapy that often
works.
Activities that elicit humor with the feared
situation, can help reduce disgust, anxiety
or whatever other uncovered feelings may be
the cause of our phobia.
What’s your experience with phobia? Have
you ever had one that you were able to overcome?
And if so, how did you do it? Share your thoughts
in the comments below.
This and all other Sprouts' videos are licensed
under the Creative Commons. That means teachers
from all around the world can use them in
classrooms, online courses or
to start projects - and today, thousands already
do!
To learn how it works and download this video
without Ads or background music, checkout
our website or read the description below.
If you want to support our mission and help
change education
visit our Patreon - that's patreon.com/sprouts.